hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2009 american science fiction and action
movie called echelon conspiracy which
tells a story about a phone that can
predict anything in the future with 100
accuracy
the movie begins with a woman in a
subway station following instructions
from a mobile phone
she waits until the train departs and
then explores the tunnel looking for
something
suddenly a train is approaching and she
manages to jump to the opposite lane but
subsequently gets hit by the other train
the scene moves to a young american
named max peterson who turns out to be
an i.t expert and is currently in
thailand to install a security system in
a company
upon arrival at the hotel the
receptionist hands him a package but he
seems confused as he didn't order
anything previously he unpacks the
package and finds a weird yet very
advanced mobile phone from gzt a brand
that none of us have ever heard of
before not long after max receives a
message from the phone suggesting he
stay one more night as there's a special
rate that weekend thinking that's a good
deal he immediately calls the
receptionist to book the room and
reschedule his flight while enjoying his
day off max learns from the news that
the plane which he was supposed to take
today crashed shortly after takeoff what
a very lucky man
shortly after a message pops up again
recommending him to buy a certain stock
but max ignores it he returns to the
room and a breaking news on tv reports
that the scissor stocks price was
somehow increased 300 that day which
shocks max because the prediction from
the message was correct
meanwhile in russia a bald man is
informed that a new phone has been
detected max begins to believe the
messages and decides to travel to prague
as soon as he landed he is approached by
a taxi guy named yuri offering him a
flat fare to which max agrees to on
their way the driver is surprised when
he sees the phone as it hasn't
officially been released yet
he then gives max's name card revealing
that yuri is actually a
telecommunications specialist whose
hobby is to repair or modify tech stuff
max arrives at a five-star hotel where
he receives another message encouraging
him to go to the casino and play at slot
machine number 13. max who is a noob at
gambling confidently enters the casino
immediately looking for the machine
unfortunately the slot machine is
occupied by another player
at the same time the message informs him
that the jackpot is coming so max pays
the player a huge amount of money to
kick him out of the machine after that
max presses the button and he somehow
hits the jackpot on his first try
winning 100 000 euros the people from
the control room become suspicious of
max questioning how he managed to know
that the machine would pay off even
willing to pay the previous player to
stop playing since max is just an
ordinary man the manager orders his
staff to track his movement instead of
cashing out the prize max exchanges all
the money with chips and proceeds with
playing blackjack just after he sits at
the table he goes all in on his first
move and eventually wins the round the
manager suspects that max gets all the
hints from his phone and calls the
security to warn him that mobiles are
prohibited in the casino
that night max calls yuri asking him to
build a device that allows him to read
text messages without looking at the
phone
back at the hotel max runs into a
fighting couple and attempts to defend
the woman camilla however he gets
knocked out and camilla uses this
opportunity to scan the phone's sim card
shortly after max awakens while camilla
acts like she cares for him on the other
hand the manager receives the sim card
data and attempts to track the sender of
the message but to no avail
a few moments later he meets yuri who
then installs the requested
text-to-speech transmitter to his phone
afterwards max returns to the casino and
does as the message suggests
he plays another slot machine and
effortlessly wins 3 million euro in one
shot
suddenly the manager and two guards show
up to detain max
he tries to escape but eventually gets
knocked out and arrested by an fbi agent
named grant
the fbi agent takes him to an abandoned
building where he interrogates him and
forces him to spill out the center of
the message
however max knows nothing about the
phone nor the sender
still clueless grant meets the casino
manager john who used to be his
colleague
grant reveals that there have been other
similar cases where americans receive
financial messages from anonymous grant
attempted to interrogate the recipients
but they all are dead they then decide
to release max on condition that he will
help them to find the culprit grant then
informs his boss raymond burke of nsa
that he still got no lead on the case
the next day max catches up with camilla
but not for a long time as jon confronts
them to pick him up they tell max to act
normal and keep following the message's
orders while he is being monitored by
burke and his team from the nsa office
max plays the game and goes all in but
somehow this time the prediction is
wrong and he loses all the money at that
moment
just after he walks out the message
warns him not to turn off the phone
again
at the same time burke and his team
finally managed to locate the exact
coordination of the sender however just
before they go deeper burke orders
everybody to shut down the system
burke seems furious and tells grant that
the source is from echelon a nsa's
advanced supercomputer that has the
ability to filter all global
communication
he immediately asks his man to identify
the culprit but he finds no input
activities on the computer the mission
is then terminated and john immediately
reports to his boss the casino owner
about echelon
the boss orders him to track max as he's
the only hint to find the real culprit
the following day grant and burke hire a
man to be max's surrogate to follow the
instruction from the message as expected
the message shows up ordering the fake
max to cross the road the light suddenly
turns red and the fake max eventually
gets hit by a car meanwhile the real max
is having a great day with camilla who
is told by jon to keep an eye on him
until the center is captured not long
after camilla spots a sniper trying to
assassinate max they luckily managed to
dodge the bullets and try to escape from
the room but two russian hitmen break
into the room to finish them off
fortunately camilla who turns out to be
a very skilled fighter is able to kill
them both jon then arrives at the room
while max finds out that they have been
working together all this time
it is revealed that the assassins were
sent by burke who wants to eliminate max
because he already knows too much
jon takes max to yuri's place in moscow
hoping that he could figure out who is
the center of the messages unfortunately
max's face is detected by the station's
cctv meaning that burke will send his
men again
upon arrival he gives yuri the sim
card's information and he promises them
that he will find the sender in three
hours
while waiting they explore the city
where jon tells max that he was kicked
out of the fbi because of burke
a few moments later they return to
yuri's place and they are shocked when
yuri tells them echelon is the one who
has been sending messages on its own all
this time
at first john does not believe him but
then yuri explains that echelon has the
capability to manipulate and access
everything including intercepting the
plane's fuel analysis that's why the
computer was able to predict that the
plane max was supposed to take would
crash he adds that echelon is very smart
allowing it to calculate every
possibility rapidly and accurately
john discovers that the apartment has
been infiltrated by burke's men and they
immediately flee with the stolen car
the car chase ensues and after a
breathtaking pursuit throughout the
moscow streets jon eventually manages to
eliminate all the men until its grant
remaining he then blows up grant's car
leaving the fbi agent badly injured
turns out that grant burke and their
team also have discovered that echelon
is sending messages on its own
he then asks for max's help to beat the
computer because he received a
threatening message lately
afterwards max receives a message which
orders them to go to a facility in omaha
a building where max installed the
security system for the first time in
his career upon arrival with the
assistance from the local swat team they
break into the building but cannot find
anything suspicious the building's cctv
camera detects max's presence and
echelon immediately sends a message to
him asking him to authorize bios which
will grant echelon unlimited access to
all data around the world unbeknownst to
him he turns on the server and computer
system inside the bunker
however nothing happens in the beginning
so grant orders everyone to empty the
bunker
not long after max returns to the
building discovering that echelon has
left the nsa system and is upgrading
itself on the other side burke is also
aware of this and finds a potential
inside echelon
max attempts to shut it down but he
can't do much as echelon now has
everyone's financial data in its
possession grant calls burke reporting
about his intention to shut down echelon
but the boss disallows him because burke
understands that echelon can become the
greatest surveillance and security tool
for america they argue for a moment and
grant makes it clear that echelon will
control everything on its own but the
boss disagrees with him
grant eventually decides to disobey his
boss and orders max to shut it down
completely as expected the swat team
under burke's order returns to the
bunker and the gunshot ensues as john
and grant refused to move away
inside the bunker max understands that
echelon has a self-learning ability so
he engages in a conversation with
echelon he questions echelon about its
real purpose to protect the us and how
echelon can be a threat to u.s citizens
personal freedoms
a lot of articles talking about echelon
as a threat appear while at the same
time the computer processes all the
information from the articles as the
update is finished echelon shuts itself
down because it finally learns that its
presence itself is a threat to the us
and the citizens after that max john and
grant are arrested it does not take a
long time until camilla shows up and
releases them she then hands max a check
of three millions dollars given by the
casino boss as a reward because he
deserves it
they then decide to go on a date to
paris at the end of the movie it's
revealed that yuri is actually not a
taxi driver or tech specialist but he is
a captain in the russian security
service his boss congratulates him for
helping the americans to make the right
decision by shutting down echelon at
least for this time
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching